okay I am getting a bit tired how
because that granola bar is still like
right there and it's not it's just
saying come on get me I only took one
bite out of it so I need some more
granola fuel so in response to e4 I I
have this move in mind it may seem a bit
awkward for me to do this because of how
much I emphasize not want you to really
obstruct the sea pond but as it has its
purpose to establish a quick ee5 move
now what else
well I think I'd do this no no no no no
no no maybe I should stop saying that in
some cases in this being one now I think
I know I should do this maybe I should
speak a bit more confidently with that
move how do I know that this is the
moment because he's not gonna go here
and because my bishop wants to come out
and see the world in this direction and
I want to support my Center for so for
all those reasons it's the right thing
to do now at this point I question
whether I should castle or not and I
also question whether I should go with
Knight a5 with the c5 move to follow or
h6 in fact I like h6 guess why because I
don't want to deal with a pesky Bishop I
don't have a dark square Bishop around
so there is no Bishop e7 stuff to break
this and this type of a pin so what do
you do what do you do what do you do all
right
this Knight is a traveler here traveling
eyeing that square hmm
the bishop here is good I'm doing this
like a plain Knight a5 and not have to
worry about a queen a4 check so let me
get know well wait a second yeah maybe
yeah I have to be very cautious of my
epon you could come under some heavy
fire with f4 and i need to be in a spot
with my queen on e5 okay no we're not
gonna have pressure on this pond I think
this should be an automatic move or
should it my knight yeah my knight wants
to go somewhere else it wants to be on
c5 taking a step in that direction
Knight b7 to c5 now that the Queen side
has closed up because of this pawn push
my king can start to think about having
the Queen side as his home I think Queen
here for starters I still haven't made
up my mind with my King and what he
wants to do where he wants to live
maybe King's side maybe Queen side I'm
pretty sure my queen wants to be on e7
I'm also pretty sure my bishop doesn't
want to go anywhere but this diagonal
because I need to be in a spot where I
take out this Knight and now that is a
pain how do I recapture if I go like
this my night is a bit stranded oh no no
no no no no no no I take away from the
center by default as the rule of thumb I
follow is to capture towards the center
unless I have a good reason not to this
right here would be castling towards the
center I didn't like having my knight
unprotected so that's why I didn't go
towards the center I also was wanted to
play Knight b7 to d6 but I could forget
about that and if I do this and get rid
of the light square Bishop Knight f5 to
kill her I have to watch out for that
so it's awkward as it may seem maybe
well actually my son is ready to
collapse it's ready to collapse here oh
wait a second
should I play pawn here with Nightbeat
ring let's try that let's try it oh you
know what else is available for white a4
with Bishop III are they listening it's
not a good move definitely don't want to
go with a forfeit should be three that's
I think that was gonna kill me yeah I
would have been tough one to stomach
right there let's get my knight in there
I'm dropping this pawn no I'm not I'm
not
Bishop takes I take this guy and then
land a check on c5 unless that move was
played well I can recall a time in I can
recall a time right now when I was
playing in over the board game this was
a tournament situation and the best move
that I had was one that looked
ridiculous but I still had to go with it
and I think this is another case of that
I went to b3 and on my next turn I go
back to a5 it's a tough one to have to
to run forward with but I have to go
with what I think is gonna be the best
move here I have to watch over that pine
that was uh that was an inaccuracy I
don't know what I was thinking
I guess I was still thinking was coming
with the fork and I could get the dark
square Bishop but that's not the case
and maybe I should be breaking at this
structure what's castle
the position can open up
see six I guess I'm gonna have to try to
open the position up to get c6 and my
bishops still should not leave the
defense of f5 after pawn takes I
recapture with my knight or maybe take
here now whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what's happening with that move that's
interesting
I'm not sure what the story is with that
hmm okay I'm up upon one minute to a
minute 30 30 second edge I'm gonna take
I'm gonna get the LightScribe bishops
off but I'm gonna recapture the pun f5 I
want to watch over it box that night out
take right here where there is Queen
check I have that on push night here
consider some tactics on this Bishop
Queen check Queen c4 that's dropping the
night I have this covered very easy to
miss the lateral movement of the Queen
happens quite a bit I see it in
high-level games see GM's file for this
believe it or not bullet bullet usually
but it happens something something to do
with that horizontal movement of the
Queen I think I'm not sure why exactly
that happens how we're more inclined to
miss the horizontal movement than the
diagonal the vertical but yeah that the
rank movement of those pieces it's tough
rook takes rook takes I'm on this twice
okay they resigned good game let's back
up let's flip because I think you had
some interesting opportunities right
there and the one that's grabbing my
attention is this position right here
maybe maybe I should have run with this
Knight move right away instead of the
Queen move so I because I think this is
an interesting pawn sack again if I take
towards the center and well I can't play
here right away but my knight is a
little bit stranded I'm not sure where
exactly it goes so that's why I went in
the other direction then Bishop there's
have been annoying after I played c4 I'm
giving white an opportunity to play on
a3 I'm seeing a few people referencing
something with the a pond to be honest I
really didn't consider taking the a pond
at all
I kind of just viewed it as just being a
pond grab and kind of going in the wrong
direction releasing some control over my
center but anyhow I think right here in
response to C for a for with Bishop a3 I
think is gonna be very uncomfortable for
my queen she's really running out of
squares so this is a problem I shouldn't
go with c4 because of this response I
think it's very good a four-night b3 is
met with first Bishop a3 and then you
react to the threat on the roof so I
think that that would be an improvement
I'd liked this idea though that was a
very interesting concept
c5 Bishop a6 and I think the the better
continuation would be something with a
four Bishop e3 and my queen is having to
run back home I'd be I definitely feel
very very uncomfortable if that was
played I don't know if there would be a
good solution
I shouldn't have been calling it the
knight b3 and well things start to get a
little bit
and here I think I'm standing well these
ponds being broken isolated and I have
homes and checks and stuff like that
this night is kind of out of play but if
a for Bishop a3 was played I think it
could have been a much different story